we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p call anytime
here's a voicemail i received let's take
a listen hey david a louis there's Josh
formatting in Virginia just want to say
thank you very much for the excellent
recommendation of the grand Budapest
hotel my epic movie I absolutely loved
it thank you again for that amazing
recommendation I'll look into more of
your recommendations thanks again and
your shows amazing a lot of it's the
best place to get real news very cool uh
yeah david pakman.com slash
recommendations we do one recommendation
a week we get a surprisingly high number
of emails for a segment that I wouldn't
necessarily assume is going to be an
audience favorite so thank you for that
and let me remind you that on today's
bonus show we will be talking about a
new hydrogen powered car from Honda lot
of talk about electric cars lately what
about hydrogen I will also talk about
Finland yet another country that is now
looking into a basic income for all
citizens and remember that you can get a
free 2016 hatred mail calendar with your
membership but you have to go to david
pakman.com slash calendar 16